[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 ya Juan Pablo lucumí está entrando a
nuestro estudio y en esta mesa de
trabajo para hablar a Juan Pablo de la
radiografía que le vamos a hacer a la
reforma de las pensiones de Francia y
vamos a empezar hablando por una
descripción general de este proyecto Así
es pero antes de esa descripción que
estamos hablando miremos un poco los
antecedentes esa es una de las reformas
que Manuel macron venía proponiendo
desde hace mucho tiempo atrás su primer
anuncio provocó semanas de protestas y
huelgas en el transporte justo antes que
llegara la pandemia del covid 19 en ese
momento macron suspendió la iniciativa y
ordenó el cierre de Francia a principios
de 2020 pero esta semana la propuesta
regresó Y esta es la descripción de la
Reforma Elevar la edad de jubilación de
62 a 64 años de edad para 2020 2030
Perdón algo de lo que ya habíamos
hablado aquí Pero algunas de las
categorías específicas como policías o
bomberos jubilarse antes los franceses
deberán pues tener trabajar un mínimo de
43 años para obtener una pensión
completa desde el 2027 y vamos a ver
también otra para aquellos que
comenzaron a trabajar antes de los 20
años podrán tener una jubilación
anticipada y la edad mínima de
jubilación para tener derecho a una
pensión completa se incrementará
gradualmente en tres meses cada año a
partir de este año
previamente nosotros hablamos con Pascal
dugo analista de política francesa quien
desde París nos explicó con términos
cotidianos la reforma para el gobierno
de qué se trata la verdad se trata de
salvar el sistema de repartición que es
el sistema francés de jubilación A
diferencia de unos países en el mundo
también en las Américas no tenemos un
sistema de capitalización es un sistema
de repartición Qué significa significa
de que los activos pagan pues para las
pensiones de de jubilación y es un
sistema que tenemos en Francia desde
el final de la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
se trata finalmente de relevar el
período de trabajo de dos años de manera
gradual para que
treinta la salida legal para que cada
activo beneficie del sistema pleno de
pensiones sea al lugar de 62 años a 64
años Juan Pablo pero también hay que
decirle una reforma que recibió más a
rechazo que aprobación y también
despertó todo el descontento de
sindicatos y llamó a varios sectores de
la población de Francia a manifestarse
en contra de esto Así es algo lo que
tenemos que hablar porque varias
encuestas han cifrado el de la
desaprobación por encima del 70 otras
por encima del 80% y vamos a revisar
aquí lo que han puesto algunos de los
principales detractores del mandatario
iniciamos con Marín Lepe en la
derechista quien pues ella perdió la
presidencia ante Manuel macron y ella
tuiteó tras ser elegido gracias a la
izquierda y la Francia en sumisa Emanuel
macron intentará ahora con el apoyo de
lr llevar la jubilación a los 64 años
los franceses pueden contar con toda
nuestra determinación para bloquear esta
reforma injusta un llamado general
básicamente al bloqueo de esta reforma
vamos con el siguiente y este es de
melonson que él dice lo que vamos a leer
aquí cambios en la edad inicial aumento
de las anualidades supresión de las
dietas especiales ventajosas la reforma
de macron y borre es un grave retroceso
social hay incluso y vamos a leer en el
siguiente personas que han hablado
también de las huelgas que van a llegar
y lo veremos en esta imagen que dice
además de ser una aberración democrática
la jubilación a los 64 años es también
una aberración social Cómo podemos
aceptar privar a tantas personas de su
derecho a jubilarse antes de morir y una
imagen acompañada que dice que 7
millones de personas mueren antes de los
65 años no a la reforma Pero ha habido
también algunas personas que han
aprobado la reforma de Emanuel macron
como el caso que veremos a continuación
la reforma provisional propuesta por
Elizabeth Board retoma la que votamos en
el senado es decir la apoya como
habíamos pedido la revalorización de las
pensiones pequeñas se han tenido en
cuenta las de las madres esto el
descontento es algo que también nos
explicó nuestro invitado a continuación
en su programa presidencial
habló de una reforma de pensiones y
hablaba de un Horizonte donde los
activos tendrían que trabajar hasta los
65 años entonces ya en Francia nos
estamos preparando pues nuevamente diría
a un debate fuerte y quizás a un
movimiento sociales que se van a
instalar tal como fue por ejemplo en
diciembre de 1995 cuando el entonces
jefe de gobierno a la yupé bajo la
presidencia
debía reformar el sistema tanto como
hubo en otros periodos y desde entonces
Juan Pablo ahora Hagamos una especie de
comparativo no entre las edades de
jubilación en los países europeos un
tema polémico porque Francia en este
momento la tiene en 62 años pero que
pues si se compara con la región es
mucho más alto y eso es lo que miraremos
acá en este mapa tema por ejemplo como
Alemania que en promedio está en 65,8 en
Suiza 67 años para los hombres la de
Francia está para una propuesta de 64
España 65 años un año y más que fue como
inició la propuesta de Francia Portugal
66,6 años en promedio Italia 67 años y
Países Bajos igual que Portugal hasta
los 66 y hasta los 67 años en 2024 algo
de lo que macron ha dicho que pues Por
esa razón básicamente es que se necesita
la reforma porque si no sería
completamente insostenible esto también
no lo explicó nuestro invitado
estamos en un país que se confronta
donde hay debates donde hay huelgas
manifestaciones pues se considera de que
los derechos adquiridos ya no son para
siempre y ahí es la dificultad porque se
está mezclando entonces la noción a la
vez de modernidad de de conciencia
social con las cifras dicen Pues que los
difíciles
si no reformamos para justamente este
horizonte de 2030 es decir dentro de
siete años son muy importantes son están
calculados a Trece mil millones de de
oro y si no se
modifica sino se reforma el sistema
llamando entonces a trabajar más
definitivamente Pues el sistema francés
de pensión puede colapsar Juan Pablo y
de esta manera llegamos al final de
economía por ese momento luego tendremos